lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
retomar la información del vídeo pasado
que tenía que ver con programadores pero
ahora de una forma un poco más visual
aquí dibujé una gráfica también
utilizando la hoja de cálculo y para
esto hice lo siguiente
puse en este eje horizontal la cantidad
de líneas de código por mes déjame
ponerle por aquí que es la cantidad de
líneas de código por mes entonces es
esta información de aquí ok esto que
estoy poniendo en un color verde
y acá en el eje vertical puse costos que
costos pues de todo tipo de los fijos
los variables y el costo total y estos
los podemos diferenciar aquí en la
gráfica según el color de la línea esta
línea verde amarilla es de costos fijos
esta línea naranja es de costos
variables y finalmente la línea azul es
del costo total vamos a ver cada una de
ellas así una por una porque hay cosas
interesantes que decir vamos a empezar
con los costos fijos para empezar
podemos ver que esto de aquí simplemente
es una línea horizontal eso no debería
de ser tan sorpresivo porque justo los
costos fijos pues están fijos no
dependen de la cantidad de programadores
pero ojo aquí tenemos líneas de código
por mes entonces es un poquito distinto
a lo que dijimos en el vídeo pasado
antes decíamos los costos fijos no
dependen de los programadores pero ahora
estamos viendo que los costos fijos
tampoco dependen de las líneas de código
por mes lo cual es más o menos intuitivo
verdad que son más o menos tiene su
explicación bueno ahora pasemos a los
costos variables éstos en efecto van
cambiando verdad van cambiando según nos
movemos hacia la derecha
pero mira aquí se van acumulando más
estos costos variables por este fenómeno
que decíamos que se va perdiendo este
que se va perdiendo utilidad adicional
con cada programador que metemos porque
se tienen que organizar pero bueno de
cualquier forma aquí tenemos esos puntos
de costos variables por ejemplo por acá
que más o menos son como nueve mil
líneas de código tenemos un costo de
como trescientos mil entonces este punto
correspondería a nueve mil líneas de
código y 300 mil de costos variables a
este de acá bueno muy bien finalmente
vamos al costo total al costo total que
es este que está en azul el costo total
si te das cuenta simplemente está 150
mil pesos arriba del costo variable es
decir nada más para obtener esta línea
azul lo que tenemos que hacer es sumar
en cada valor de líneas de código por
mes estas dos funciones las de costos
fijos y las de costos variables como el
costo fijo es fijo pues es constante
entonces esta línea siempre están
separadas por la misma cantidad ahora
una cosa curiosa con estas líneas es que
se encharcan que aquí cuando nos
acercamos a muchas líneas de código
como que se chocan hacia la izquierda y
la explicación para esto es justo esto
que platicábamos en el vídeo pasado
acerca de que tener más programadores
disminuye la eficiencia justo estamos
pagando por más programadores sin
embargo eso causa tener menos líneas de
código porque hay programadores que
tienen que volver a hacer el trabajo
porque hay más juntas porque hay más
distracciones ok nada más déjame marcar
por aquí los colores correspondientes
estos costos variables en naranja y
estoy acá es costo total el que esté en
azul muy bien entonces eso es con
respecto a los costos fijos variables y
el total pero ahora quiero hablar acerca
de los costos promedio también fijos
variables y total y para esto voy a
hablar en términos dependientes ahora sí
si no te es muy familiar el término
dependiente te recomiendo que veas los
los vídeos que tengo en la sección de
álgebra pendiente
básicamente la idea detrás es es que tan
inclinada está una recta entonces por
ejemplo aquí tenemos esta recta y esta
otra una forma de medir qué tan
inclinadas están es checar cuánto
cambiamos en de este punto a este punto
de acá le voy a poner aquí que el cambio
en yen y ver pues esto como es con
respecto al cambio en x o sea de aquí
acá de aquí a que este cambio bueno
entonces cuando tenemos una recta así
definimos la pendiente o sea justo la
pendiente la pendiente es igual al
cambio en james dividido entre el cambio
en x
muy bien entonces qué sucedería con esta
recta de acá por ejemplo esta parece
tener un cambio en x similar a la de la
izquierda es un poquito más grande pero
similar y un menor cambio en ya va
entonces el cambio en x es igual el
cambio y es el cambio es un poco más
chiquito entonces la pendiente va a ser
más chiquita porque el numerador se hace
más pequeño entonces aquí le pongo que
tiene menor menor pendiente pendiente
de modo similar si tenemos una recta más
o menos así entonces ahora su cambio en
cambio en lleva a ser muy grande su
cambio en lleva a ser chiquito el
numerador es grande el denominador es
pequeño entonces este tiene una
pendiente alta le voy a poner así nada
más pendiente
muy bien pero que tienen que ver estás
pendientes de rectas con nuestros costos
fijos promedio o costos variables
promedio o costo total promedio bueno
vamos a pensar un poquito en cómo
calculamos este costo fijo promedio
justo lo encontramos dividiendo este
costo fijo 150 mil pesos entre la
cantidad de líneas de código por mes que
son cuatro mil muy bien pero déjame
marcar un punto por acá lo voy a poner
con este color y rosa muy notorio déjame
marcar este punto de acá y cuánto es
esta altura o sea cuánto es esta altura
de acá pues esta altura de acá justo es
150.000 si es 150.000 porque es el costo
fijo y cuánto es ésta está bueno cuánto
mide esta línea horizontal que estoy
marcando pues esta línea horizontal mide
la cantidad de líneas de código es decir
entonces qué pasa si nos fijamos en el
cambio en y dividido entre el cambio en
x pues justo estamos haciendo 150.000
entre 4000 estamos encontrando el costo
fijo promedio entonces precisamente el
costo fijo promedio es la pendiente que
se hace desde el 0 0 hasta este punto de
acá es la pendiente que tiene esta recta
sale esta recta de acá de modo similar
este 21.43 es la pendiente que tiene
esta recta de acá
y observa aquí tenemos bueno aquí
tenemos una recta con una cierta
pendiente que está inclinada de cierta
forma pero esta otra recta de acá está
inclinada está menos inclinada está un
poco más horizontal entonces tiene una
menor pendiente lo cual tiene sentido
porque refleja un menor costo fijo
promedio que habíamos dicho que venía de
dividir el costo fijo entre una mayor
cantidad de líneas de código por mes ok
entonces ahí ya tenemos esta
interpretación en términos dependientes
de los costos fijos promedios son la
pendiente de cada punto en esta línea
horizontal al cero cero vamos a pensar
qué sucede ahora con los costos
variables promedio entonces déjame
ponerle que esto lo puse en color rosa
para ir llevando la la cuenta de que
estamos haciendo ahora voy a pasarme al
color morado y ahora con los costos
variables promedio va a pasar algo muy
similar
otra vez lo que estamos haciendo es
dividir estos 100 mil pesos entre la
cantidad de líneas entonces ahora
estamos dividiendo esta cantidad
bueno aquí serían 100.000 aquí serían
200.000 vamos a poner 200.000 para que
no quede tan encima do con con el otro
ejemplo entonces serían estos 200 mil
dividido entre las siete mil líneas de
código que tenemos entonces ahora es la
pendiente pero no hacia un punto de la
línea verde verde amarilla sino ahora
hacia un punto de esta línea que es más
como naranja abraham naranja roja
entonces ahora lo que tenemos es esta
línea de acá que acabo de dibujar ojalá
no nos está enseñando mucho con las
rosas pero es esta de acá
y de modo similar ahora si queremos
digamos el costo variable promedio para
este punto para las 10.000 líneas de
código o sea cuatro programadores
entonces ahora tenemos esta línea de acá
bueno déjame borrar un poquito para para
decirte algo al respecto
mira teníamos por acá un primer punto
verdad este es el primer punto naranja y
que sucedió con la pendiente de esta
recta va a quedar un poco encima do pero
bueno de esta recta con esta recta de
acá
pues esta recta tiene una pendiente
hacia chiquita y luego estar acá tiene
una pendiente pues un poco más grande
entonces eso quiere decir que el costo
variable promedio aumentó de modo
similar otra vez va a crecer la
pendiente yéndonos hacia este punto y
entonces el costo variable promedio va a
ir aumentando y aumentando que tiene que
ver con este fenómeno de que se va
perdiendo utilidad por cada programador
adicional bueno ok entonces eso es una
observación importante y finalmente
vamos al costo variable este lo voy a
poner con un color como rosa baja este d
con este color rosa de acá y de modo
similar el costo y el costo total perdón
ahora vamos al costo total promedio el
costo total es la pendiente otra vez de
puntos pero ahora sobre la recta azul
hacia el 0 0 así éste este hacia este
punto de acá entonces déjame trazar
algunas líneas para ver qué sucede
tenemos al 0 0 luego aquí tenemos otra
aquí está pasando algo interesante
observa como la pendiente empieza a
siendo alta pero luego disminuye luego
se queda igual bueno más o menos igual
debería de ser igual porque los dos son
50 y luego vuelve a crecer entonces una
vez más podemos interpretar este costo
total promedio como pendientes que van
del 0 0 a estos puntos de acá porque
porque justo el costo total promedio es
dividir el costo total entre la cantidad
de líneas de código por mes entonces
digamos si tenemos este costo total de
por acá que es como 600 y cachito debe
ser este 650 mil estamos lo que estamos
haciendo al obtener el costo total
promedio es dividir esos 650 mil que es
este cambio en este cambio dividido
entre las 10.000 líneas de código
las 10.000 o más bien este punto de acá
el que había dicho verdad las 10 mil 600
líneas de código ok entonces otra vez
ahí tenemos una interpretación en
término de pendiente para el costo total
promedio ya nada más déjame pasar al
costo marginal promedio y ese tiene un
poquito más de chiste déjame borrar
algunas de las líneas a ésta
y el costo marginal promedio es un poco
más interesante porque antes con los
costos fijos promedio costos variables
promedio y el costo total promedio
teníamos rectas que iban hacia el origen
pero el costo marginal promedio no lo
estamos calculando así por ejemplo
déjame tomar un punto un punto
arbitrario digamos este de acá va
entonces este 50 de dónde salió este 50
habíamos dicho que el costo marginal
promedio es cuánto tenemos que pagar por
cada línea adicional entonces lo que
hacíamos era hacer el costo total de
aquí y a eso le restamos el costo total
del caso anterior y luego dividimos
entre la cantidad de líneas menos la
cantidad de líneas anterior es decir la
diferencia de costo total entre la
diferencia de líneas de código por mes
como ya hacemos para encontrar eso en la
gráfica donde está este 45.000 pues nos
vamos al costo total para ver dónde está
el 45.000
es más o menos esté de por acá luego nos
vamos al 35.000 es este de acá
y eso lo tenemos que entonces bueno que
estamos haciendo es este menos éste ahí
tenemos un cambio de verdad es esta
altura menos esta altura eso nos da un
cambio en y un cambio en y eso lo
estamos dividiendo entre 9.000 menos
7.000 o sea entre esto de atrás aunque
un poco chueco voy a agarrar la
herramienta de línea entre esto de acá
entre estos 9.000 menos estos 7.000
7.000 entonces estoy acá es un cambio en
x y entonces ahora en qué consiste el
costo marginal promedio pues el costo
marginal promedio no consiste en la
pendiente de una recta al gel origen
sino en pendientes de puntos que ven
bueno independientes de las líneas entre
puntos consecutivos jaja y aparece
trabalenguas entre puntos consecutivos
del costo total entonces tenemos por
ejemplo esta línea de acá que tiene una
cierta pendiente esos son los 50 luego
tenemos esta línea de acá que serían
estos ya que son 100 luego está de acá
que sería 166 y observa que aquí como
que nos vamos hacia atrás y por eso
tenemos las pendientes negativas muy
bien entonces aquí tenemos estas
pendientes entonces una vez más los
costos fijos variables y costo total son
estas rectas que dibujamos
respectivamente son la verdecita la
naranja roja y ésta y ésta como color
azul esta ésta y ésta
después los costos fijos promedio
variables promedio y total promedio son
pendientes de puntos sobre esas rectas
que ya habíamos definido hacia el origen
y finalmente el costo marginal promedio
era tomarse las pendientes pero entre
puntos sus sucesivos de esto de la de la
línea del costo total o bien de hecho o
sea si quieres también puedes pensarlo
como la pendiente de la otra línea de
los costos variables porque como una es
una trasladada de la otra entonces
tienen exactamente las mismas pendientes